i can hear the crowd i can hear my
competitors running i can hear the track
spikes i feel my heartbeat
and i'll never forget i'm running and
i'm smiling it was my moment in time
kevin young the gold medalist a new
world record tom
you've held this world record for 29
years
28 years and 11 months kevin young is a
former olympic hurdler
and up until the night before this
interview he held the world record for
the 400 meter hurdles event
carson warhol bested him by .08 seconds
during the tokyo olympic trials
and a few days before that sydney
mclaughlin broke the woman's world
record for the 400 meter hurdles
it's an event that's over in under a
minute and olympic athletes make it look
effortless
but it's not as simple as running and
jumping it's actually one of the most
demanding races
on the track
[Music]
so you got to deal with the endurance
factor the the speed factor it's a
quarter mile so it's a fast race
the cross between sprinting and hurdling
puts these athletes in a unique position
they need to train to run at the speed
of a race half the length
and build the endurance needed for a
race at least twice the length
around the track are 10 hurdles evenly
spaced 35 meters apart
to get over them hurdlers have to make
the most of the three energy systems in
the human body
typically for the first two hurdles off
the blocks the goal is to fire up to
race speed
the first eight to twelve seconds of a
race athletes tap into energy reserves
in their muscles
which is fine for short explosive races
like the hundred meter dash
during war homes race you can hear the
announcer say he reacted to that gun
like a 100 meter sprinter but after
about 10 seconds
that energy system is spent and there's
still at least another 300 meters and
plenty of hurdles to go
for the next three to five hurdles
athletes have to focus on maintaining
their speed using the two other energy
systems
one needs oxygen to help them with
endurance as they move through the race
the other produces energy fast without
oxygen but leads to that familiar muscle
burn
if they move too fast they'll burn out
and have trouble clearing hurdles later
on
by hurdles six through eight they're
coming around that final bend and they
need to give it their all to not lose
speed
this is where you see kevin young surge
ahead in the 1992 barcelona olympics
kevin young has the lead
i got to the eighth hurdle i literally
took off away from the field
my stride was open i was moving and i
just pulled away from everybody
at this point legs start to feel heavier
and those hurdles start to look higher
when talking about hurdles 9 and 10 one
track coach i spoke with said
it's sheer willpower from that last
hurdle there's still another 40 meters
to the finish line to sprint
but mastering endurance and speed means
nothing if you're not clearing the
hurdles
efficiently and this is what really sets
the 400 meter hurdles apart
the race isn't just physically taxing
it's highly technical
it's all about being on the track
running that's when you get your speed
from
the hurdles do to slow you down hurdlers
don't jump
per se they sort of sprint right over
the hurdles
the goal is to spend as little time in
the air as possible
the first leg over the hurdle called the
lead lake should already be pushing down
to the ground as the trail lake follows
over the hurdle
once they hit the ground they're focused
on the next turtle you have to establish
a particular rhythm in the race
when athletes like young talk about
rhythm they're talking about how many
steps they take between each hurdle
i remember when i started running the
hurdles i would run up on the hurdle
trying to go 13 steps between the
hurdles because the master edwin moses
did it
i would always chop steps which is why
stride patterns are carefully calculated
and practiced
long before the starting gun like in
young's 1992 world record breaking race
stick with your stride pattern the
stride pattern was 20 to the first
13 to 2 13 to 3
12 12 for four hurdles four and five
then back to 13 for her to six through
10 and 18 steps from the 10th hurdle to
the finish line
rhythm matters for two reasons one so
you don't stutter coming up to a hurdle
or clip it like young did on the tenth
hurdle of his 1992 race
and two so you can control which leg is
the lead leg
so if you're going 13 steps you're on
one consistent leg
your dominant leg you're going 14 steps
you're going left right left right left
right
top athletes can lead with either leg
but it's not uncommon for them to have a
favorite
if you have a leg that you don't you're
not used to hurling with you may take it
and it'll twist you all up and have you
off balance and you'll just be hoping
and praying that you'd laying on the
other side of the hurdle
finding and perfecting the right pattern
is what drives the best athletes forward
but it's not a one-size-fits-all
approach
just as kevin young couldn't break the
world record following the techniques of
edwin moses
carson warhol couldn't use kevin young's
methods he went out harder than i would
ever run
when 13 to 9 in the 10th hurdle he went
15 and he just
went over and it was just speed speed at
the end of a well-practiced
well-executed plan i know how how well i
ran and my success in the sport
itself i said these guys are going to
take it to a whole level
[Music]
you